Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Conner's. Welcome to another Read Your Genes podcast where we go over your questions on genetics. Wait a few come in. So let's get started on the few questions that we have.
Remember everybody to be looking at the course watches many of the videos as you can on the course. It's always your best way to get questions answered but we're here to answer anything you have like this one. I'm trying to understand the gluten genes. So the HLA genes on the on your genetic workup.
So your gluten genes, does that mean you have a gluten sensitivity? No. So the gluten genes are the HLA and the KIA genes for celiac. Give us the idea that you have a greater chance of having gluten sensitivity, the KIA genes, a greater chance of having celiac disease.
That's a question we often get. Well, you told me not to eat gluten. I don't have any issues with eating gluten. Well, you if you have a lot of defects on the HLA gene and or a lot of defects on the KIA gene and you're still eating gluten with no apparent symptoms.
Does that mean that you don't have hidden health conditions due to eating gluten? So we often think that a food sensitivity is tied directly to gut problems, stomachache, a diarrhea, constipation, et cetera, after eating the food.
So gluten sensitivity is typically doesn't really show up for 16 hours after you eat the food. So I mean, if you're eating gluten on a daily basis, you could have symptoms constantly, but it can be symptoms that are totally not gut related.
So you do inflammation in the brain, cloudy thinking, early brain degeneration, early Alzheimer's disease, all been tied to gluten.
So if you have the HLA genes and the KIA genes, and I recommend that you're not to eat gluten, you really probably should have shared that.
If you have a side note, even if you have no defects on the HLA genes and the KIA genes, you can still have a gluten sensitivity.
So do not think that just because you don't you have perfect HLA genes and perfect KIA genes that you don't still have gluten sensitivity.
So if you have a true gluten sensitivity, it's not through the genetic test, but do eat a Cyrex panel.
So you can run those through the course, you can run a Cyrex array two array three X and array four, or do a full array 10.
And that will give you full knowledge whether you have gluten sensitivity or not the two, three X are the four are the best ones for that.
So the other food sensitivity is on any other foods, the rate 10, goes over 100 different foods, cooked and raw, and that's how you're really going to find out and have sensitivities, not through genetics.
If you have the HLA and the KIA genes, defects on those genes, you should just be staying off of the gluten no matter what, whether you have symptoms or not, whether you even have a sensitivity or not,
because the chance of that causing problems is very high.
How come the dairy gene is backwards? I think what this person means by this question is that the MCM6 gene is that's a gene for lactose making lactase.
So the sugar in dairy is lactose, and it's broken down by an enzyme called lactase, and defects on the MCM6 gene actually increase your ability to produce lactase.
So you have a lesser chance of having lactose intolerance, inability to produce lactase, if you have those defects.
Remember, some defects are, you know, hereditary changes that are for the better, this is not very many, but this is one of those.
Now, understand that the MCM6 gene talks nothing about KC, which is the protein in dairy.
It's the protein in dairy that you have sensitivities to.
You may not make a lot of lactase, therefore you have lactose intolerance, therefore you would drink milk or eat ice cream with lactose in it.
You get a stomachache, you get diarrhea, that's lactose intolerance because you don't make a lot of lactase.
Well, you could solve that problem by getting lactose free milk or taking a lactase enzyme with your consumption of dairy products.
But we talk about a dairy sensitivity, we're talking about a key scene sensitivity, it's the protein in dairy.
So remember, just like the gluten genes, the MCM6 gene really has nothing to do with dairy sensitivity and literally has zero to do with dairy sensitivity.
So in order to find out if you have a dairy sensitivity, you have to do a sensitivity test, not a genetic test.
So sensitivities come and go, antibodies to foods can come and go, has nothing to do with genetics.
You know, you will have a greater chance of having a gluten problem with the HLA gene, but you have to look at a workup on your foods and TVs that is antibody testing and the best test out there in my opinion is the Syrex test.
So Syrex, panel 2, array 2, array 3x, array 4, array 10 are the things to look at for food sensitivities.
And again, you can order those on our course through our partner loop of labs.
And the last question of the day, the FUT genes, what should I do with lots of defects?
If they have a lot of defects on the FUT genes that suggestive issues that with your gut healing process.
So you really want to support that.
It depends on what other conditions you have.
So those just directly genetic defects on that gene, you want to increase your consumption of dietary fibers, you want to take things like fiber product, take things that we've got healing products out there like our clear GI or the SBI clear SBI pro or the sun spectrum, those kind of products.
But you also have to weigh that out with other things. Do I have, you know, food sensitivities that are causing inflammation? Do I have, you know, there's just so many other things you want to weigh that out with.
I typically don't recommend supplements with for somebody with FUT gene defects because there's so many other things that I want to support.
I typically just recommend supporting that with dietary changes, cleaning up your diet, looking for food sensitivities as a key component to that.
Increasing your fiber that I just talked about, that's what I would do with FUT to gene defects.
And look at the rest of the gut gene defects in that category on your, on your full report to.
And remember again with any gene defects, it doesn't mean you're guaranteed to have problems nor does it mean your guarantee to be free of problems with no defects in that category has to do with epigenetics much more than anything else you want to look at all your lifestyle changes.
Alright, I think that's the last question for the day. Make sure if you have questions that you submit them on this page on the member site. That's how they get answered.
Alright, everybody have a blessed day. Don't let I pray it for you. Bye bye.